- [Interviewer] All right, Andrea.
- Hi.
- Welcome back.
- [Andrea] Actually, it's good to be back.
- [Interviewer] How's everything with you?
- Ah, so and so.
Trying to weather the heat.
- [Interviewer] Yeah it's very hot.
- The heat's a bit much for
me, but I'm handling it.
- [Interviewer] How's your,
does your hotel room
have air conditioning?
- No, I don't have air conditioning,
I don't even have a fan right now,
I just keep my door open.
- [Interviewer] What's your favorite thing
about living in Skid Row?
Is there anything you like about Skid Row?
- I can afford my rent
and the food is free.
Afford my rent and the food is free,
that's my favorite things about Skid Row.
- [Interviewer] What about the rent?
- That's my favorite
things about Skid Row,
I can't afford my rent
and the food is free.
- [Interviewer] You can afford your rent
Do you have anything that you
don't like about Skid Row?
- When you're walking down the street,
sometimes minding your own business,
and somebody tries to sell you dope,
and you're trying to ignore them,
and they're like, carry,
carry, carry, carry, carry.
That's one of the, that's
bad side about Skid Row.
- [Interviewer] So you,
I know you smoke spice,
have you tried any other drugs,
crack or crystal meth, or heroin?
- I have a past with crack.
- [Interviewer] You
have a past with crack?
- Yeah, I got saved from Jesus
Christ to get off of crack.
11 years ago.
And I got saved by Jesus
Christ to get off of crack,
because I was an evil,
scandalous bitch on that shit.
I am a scandalous queen,
I'm a queen selfish kind of person.
Oh when I was on crack, I was
strung on crack (indistinct)
I was evil.
- [Interviewer] What
does spice help you do?
- It doesn't make me do
anything, it helps me relax.
It helps me relax.
- [Interviewer] Relaxing's good.
Are you happy, Andrea,
do you think you're happy
with your life here?
- No, I'm not happy,
that's why I need drugs.
- [Interviewer] That's why you need what?
- I said I'm not happy,
that's why I need drugs.
- [Interviewer] The drugs
make you, makes it all easier?
- That's one of the things I
need drugs for, to be happy.
- [Interviewer] Is it your childhood
that you're trying to hide the most?
Trying to forget about the most?
- No, I'm not trying to
forget about my childhood,
all I'm trying to do, I'm trying
to deal with my present life.
- [Interviewer] Your place in life?
- I'm trying to deal with my present life,
it's not about my past.
- [Interviewer] Your present life.
What would make you happiest today?
- Huh?
- What would make you happiest
what would solve your problems today?
- If the Devil would drop dead
and (indistinct) came back in my life.
That would make me happy.
- [Interviewer] Say it again.
- If the Devil would drop
dead and (indistinct) walked
back into my life, I would be happy.
- [Interviewer] Something
about drop dead--.
- If Satan, The Devil, dropped dead,
and my friend Sabri McGrennor
came back in my life.
- Oh I see.
- That would make me happy.
Understood.
Having a good friend would
really help a lot, right?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Now, how does
Satan come into your life?
You say Satan--.
- Satan persecutes my best chances.
- [Interviewer] I'm sorry?
- Satan persecutes me.
- [Interviewer] Satan persecutes you?
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] What does he make you do?
- He doesn't make me do anything,
he persecutes me and causes
me to lose sleep and appetite
to eat and stuff.
- [Interviewer] Do you think you're
on a self destructive path,
and Satan is kind of--?
- No, I'm not on a self destructive path.
- [Interviewer] No?
How does Satan come into
your life, what does he do?
- [Andrea] He persecutes me
for being saved Christian,
but that's okay, I can handle it.
Devil persecutes me for
being saved Christian,
but that's all right, I can deal with it.
- [Interviewer] Being a Christian?
- [Andrea] Yes!
- [Interviewer] Okay.
What are you gonna do later on today?
I'm gonna give you $40 for this,
what are you gonna do with it?
- [Andrea] I plan on going
and getting something
to eat after I go take my TB meds.
Anymore questions?
- [Interviewer] You gonna buy some spice?
- [Andrea] Probably.
- [Interviewer] Should I feel guilty
that I'm giving you money for drugs?
- [Andrea] No, you shouldn't.
- [Interviewer] Why not?
- [Andrea] You're helping
me, not harming me.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, well I'm helping you
from doing something more dangerous
for that money for drugs, right?
- [Andrea] No, you're not.
I'm fine.
- [Interviewer] No, but if
I didn't give you money,
you would still get your drugs somehow.
- I'm sure I'll find another way.
- [Interviewer] That's what I'm saying.
So it depends on how
deeply I wanna look at it,
the guilt goes away once
you really analyze it.
- I don't pay no mind to it.
- [Interviewer] Do you
have happy days still?
Do you wake up one day and
go, man today's a good day?
- Not too often.
- No?
You're just kinda surviving now?
- Yeah.
- Do you get depressed?
- Not really, just not happy either.
- [Interviewer] Do you see doctors?
For like health issues
or mental health issues,
or anything like that?
- I go Wesley Ester every day
to be treated for TB meds,
that's the only doctor I'm having.
- [Interviewer] TB, tuberculosis?
- Yes.
- You have tuberculosis?
- Yeah and it's an inactive kind,
that's why I'm out of the hospital,
it's not contagious, but I have TB.
We about done?
- [Interviewer] Yeah, we're about done.
Last time I asked you if
there's anything interesting
about your life, and
you probably gave me the
most interesting answer I could imagine.
Is there anything else about
Andrea that I don't know?
Pretty hard to top the last one.
- I don't know what to say to that.
- [Interviewer] You hit
a grand slam last time,
so to ask you to hit another
grand slam would be a lot.
I won't do that to you.
Back to that, the hermaphrodite
confession, secret
that you revealed.
How does that affect your life?
Does it affect your life?
- Not really.
- [Interviewer] You just have
some additional equipment.
- Right, yes.
- [Interviewer] And it's more
enjoyable for you, is it?
- If I have a long term
girlfriend, it's enjoyable.
- [Interviewer] You what?
- If I have a long term
girlfriend, it's enjoyable.
- [Interviewer] If you
have a lesbian girl--.
- Other than that, I don't
use it, except for peeing.
- [Interviewer] Got it.
So you pee out of your male equipment?
- Yeah, I pee, (indistinct)
I can't whip it out,
I can't hold it in my hands like you.
I have to stand like this,
or I have to pee outside,
stand up like this by the
subway and I go (mouth whizzes).
- [Interviewer] Yeah, I see
you peeing outside sometimes.
That's why I have a hard time
imagining you as a nurse,
when I see you pee in
the street in public.
(Andrea laughing)
- Oh boy.
- [Interviewer] What's
your favorite thing to eat?
If I give you money, you're
gonna use it for food,
what kind of food you gonna get?
- I love the food at Corner Cafe.
You know, Corner Cafe over
there at 7th and Maple?
- Yeah.
- I like their food.
- [Interviewer] What're you gonna get?
- [Andrea] I like the Philly cheese steak
with onion and rice.
- [Interviewer] Oh, that sounds good.
Excellent, all right,
Andrea, thank you for coming
by and talking with me again.
- Thank you.
- [Interviewer] Enjoy
your Philly cheese steak.
- [Andrea] I will, thank you.